pues en este vídeo estoy bastante
emocionado porque ya casi acabamos los
los ejercicios los problemas de esta
sección número 7 así que espero que en
este vídeo nos pueda acabar y estamos en
el problema del número 18 problema
número 18 y tiene una figura bastante
extraña y vamos a hacerla así que vamos
a dibujar dos tengo uno de color azul
que va a ser más o menos esto viene por
aquí cruza por acá y después que cruzan
y vuelve a bajar por acá y después
vuelve a pasar por acá
ok tengo algo así después con otro color
tengo a otra línea parecida a ésta es
algo que viene por acá cruza por acá y
después se mantiene así y por último
tengo otra de otro color y esto lo que
hace es mantenerse por acá por acá y
después cruce por acá y se va para acá
y me dicen que esta es la línea a estas
líneas está la línea c este es el inicio
el inicio aquí tengo el paso número uno
paso número uno aquí tengo por acá tengo
el paso número dos el paso número 2
esto es lo que me dice y de hecho te
aparece una pintura un poco extraña tal
vez parece un poco de arte moderno no
los hermanos al que me es el problema en
la figura siguiente tengo tres alambres
que están trenzados y estos son alambres
tengo tres alambres y le pongo el azul
el de pulgar amarillo y el de color rojo
en el primer paso unos cambian de orden
y si date cuenta que aquí en el paso 1
el alambre
pasa para acá aquí tengo el alambre a
después el alambre pasa para acá en el
de 9 pasa para acá y en el alambre se
pasa para acá se mantiene igual y en el
paso 250 que otra vez cambien de lugar
se mantienen pero ahora el 6 se pasa
para acá y enlace pasado para acá es
decir alternadamente se intercambian con
el alambre que está en el centro el
alambre que está a la izquierda y
después del hambre que está derecha y
después la izquierda y después en la
derecha se trae se está en cuántos pasos
los alambres regresan a la posición
original ok a vez de ambos podemos
pensar un poco en el paso número 3 paso
número 3
bueno la tf cuenta que el paso número 1
el que está a la izquierda pasó en medio
y el que está en medio paso a la
izquierda y éste se mantuvo igual pero
en el paso 2 ahora cambia el de la
derecha el de la derecha paso en medio
el del medio paso a la derecha y se
mantuvo igual el de la izquierda en el
paso número 3 que va a pasar pues van a
cambiar y ahora va a cambiar ahora le
toca al de la izquierda entonces
seguramente el vez se va a cambiar con
él se va a quedar algo sin el c por aquí
él ve por acá y enlace va a mantener es
decir el que está en medio se va a pasar
a la izquierda el que está en la
izquierda se va a pasar en medio
y el de la derecha se mantiene lo que
hicimos fue cambiar estos dos ok ahora
estamos cambiando el de la izquierda en
el paso número 4 en el paso número 4
pues tenemos una idea de qué va a pasar
ahora los que van a cambiar son los de
la derecha y entonces el c se va a
mantener después vamos a cambiar aquí al
am y después aquí al be ok y en el paso
número 5 en el paso número 5 pues vamos
a cambiar ahora estos dos es decir que
los que van a cambiar son los de la
izquierda y me va a quedar al c
este es el que no va a cambiar el de la
derecha y qué es lo que me preguntan en
cuántos pasos los alambres regresan a la
posición original la posición original
recuerda que es ha de ser a ver si
entonces de ac/dc a se ve y se debe
hacer y aquí aquí ya que acabamos porque
en el paso número seis en el paso número
6 que va a pasar
van a cambiar estos dos por lo tanto me
va a quedar
de lujo que expuso lo que queríamos en
el paso número 6 obtenemos nuestra
respuesta correcta después de seis pasos
regresamos al a la posición original que
es abc entonces esa es mi respuesta
correcta que es el inciso de y bueno en
este problema tan raro que parece hasta
un poco artístico lo que te recomiendo
es que vayas haciendo paso por paso la
metodología para que te des cuenta y
entiendes perfectamente qué es lo que
está pasando en el problema bueno el
problema número 18 estuvo bastante
entretenido me gustó mucho me gustan los
problemas que no son
cotidianos porque no son los típicos
problemas pero vamos a hablar ahora del
problema número 19 el problema número 19
que dice lo siguiente en un conjunto de
11 números distintos 11 números
distintos cuál de los siguientes incisos
no puede afectar el valor de la mediana
ok tengo 11 números distintos así que
bueno no sé en cuál les hayan pensado en
este problema
pero qué te parece si nosotros ponemos
aquí 11 números que sean distintos y se
me ocurre para más fácil el 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 y el 11 aquí tengo 11 números a
ver 12 3 y si tengo 11 números y los 11
son distintos te das cuenta ok entonces
si lo que me piden son 11 números
distintos pues aquí los tienes ahora lo
que me dicen es que me fijé en la
mediana cual es la mediana de estos once
números bueno pues la mediana se que
está en medio así que tendría que tener
a cinco para acá uno dos tres cuatro o
cinco para camps y cinco para cada uno
dos tres cuatro cinco este este de aquí
es la mediana la mediana de este de mi
conjunto de once números distintos ok
ahora me dice cuál de los siguientes
incisos no puede afectar el valor de la
mediana veamos cada uno de ellos enciso
duplicando cada número
ok creo que aquí si afectaría a mi
mediana y lo podemos pensar de la
siguiente manera este se va a ir a el 2
está el 4 este el 6 este al 8 y entonces
el 6 el 6 se va a ir al 12 por lo tanto
no tengo en la misma mediana tengo ahora
una mediana de 12 y eso quiere decir que
la mediana no se conserva entonces el
inciso
no es mi respuesta correcta va a
mantenerse justo aquí la mediana pero la
mediana ya no va a ser 6 va a ser 12 y
por lo tanto no es la misma inciso
número b sumándole 10 a cada número
ok creo que esto es lo mismo si le sumó
10 a todos a todos estos entonces la
mediana va a ser 16 pero no va a ser 6
lo que quiere decir que justo a la mitad
me va a quedar el 16 realicéis no es lo
mismo que el 6 y por lo tanto tampoco es
el inciso b inciso c aumentando
solamente el número más pequeño ok esto
tampoco funciona muy agradable fíjate en
el número más pequeño es uno que te
parece si a este número le sumamos
11 unidades pues lo voy a llevar de aquí
hasta acá y entonces en lugar de ser a 1
voy a obtener un 12 entonces éste no va
estar aquí déjame cruzarlo un poco
porque nos vamos a olvidar de él si
nosotros quitamos a este 1 y lo mandamos
para acá sumándole 11 unidades
le voy a sumar 11 unidades entonces la
mediana ya no va a ser 6 fíjate qué va a
cambiar necesitaría tener 1 2 3 4 5 6
este este se convertiría en mi mediana
porque aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 ó 5 tenemos 5
números en la derecha 5 números en la
izquierda y ya cambio mediana de ceder 6
a ser 7 y tampoco es tampoco es el éxito
sé si le aumentamos solamente una cierta
cantidad al número más pequeño y bueno
tú puedes reflexionar un poco en esto
pero en serio haz tú el ejercicio
aumenta este 1 y pásalo hasta que
aumenta de 11 hasta llegar a hacer 12 y
si lo mandas hacer 12 o 13 o cualquier
número más grande que que 11 entonces me
metían en ese momento va a cambiar ya no
va a ser
y va a ser 7 el inicio de dice
decreciendo solamente el número más
grande ya me lo imaginaba aquí me están
diciendo lo contrario es decir me voy a
tomar el 11 y ahora a este 11 lo voy a
decrecer pero tampoco es la opción
correcta
imagínate que este 11 le quitó 11 y lo
mandó para acá le voy a quitar 11 y lo
mandó al 0 si lo mandó al 0 este 11 va a
desaparecer de aquí y entonces me va a
quedar 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 y si te
das cuenta en este caso tengo 1 2 3 4 5
números la derecha 1 2 3 4 5 números a
la izquierda y mediana me quedaría
siendo el 5 y el 5 no es lo mismo que el
6 por lo tanto mi mediana cambio y otra
vez todo me indica que la mediana no se
mantiene entonces este tampoco es mi
respuesta es tan sencillo que busco si
al onceno decrecemos no llegamos a la
misma mediana así que el swan no es el b
tampoco el c tampoco el de tampoco
supongo que va a terminar siendo él
veamos qué dice inciso y aumentando
solamente el número más grande ahora sí
si nosotros fijamos ok déjame todos está
muy raro déjame ponerlos otra vez aquí 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 y 11
ok aquí tengo mis 11 números y ahora
imagínate que a este 11 lo voy a sumar
lo que sea entonces en lugar del 11 lo
voy a quitar y voy a poner no sé le voy
a sumar a mucho hasta que lleguemos al
1000 nosotros llegamos al 1000 y
nosotros contamos 5 números a la derecha
y 5 números de la izquierda voy a tener
1 2 3 4 5 y por acá 1 2 3 4 5 y llegamos
a la mediana y la mediana es 6 perfecto
entonces si nosotros aumentamos el
último número
parece ser que llegamos a que otra vez
mi mediana sea 6 que es justo lo que yo
quería haber si aumentamos el 11 hasta
hasta no sé se me ocurre
300.000 hasta 300.000 también van a
seguir manteniendo 65 a la derecha y 50
izquierda
123 45 a la derecha y 123 45 a la
izquierda y por lo tanto mi mediana
sigue siendo 6 sea cual sea el número al
cual llegue después de aumentarle a mi
número 11 sea cual sea
si yo aumento el número 11 voy a seguir
manteniendo a mí misma mediana la
mediana de 6 y esa es la respuesta
correcta la mediana que por cierto
quedamos que era el insisto ok
volvemos la pantalla y vamos a hablar
del problema número 20 y el programa
número 20 tiene una gráfica un poco
extraña más realmente no está muy
extraña pero me va a costar un poco de
trabajo pintarla justo aquí otra vez no
tarde mucho en pintarlas no quiero
confundirte por lo tanto creo que lo
mejor es que paren este vídeo y le haga
un vídeo especial al problema número 20
que es el último de esta sección así que
en el siguiente vídeo trataré
este problema número 20 y es podría
empezar con el dibujo lo voy a trabajar
con mucha calma y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo el vídeo especial para
el último problema de esta sección
número 7 de este examen número 6 hasta
la próxima